Allora quello che vi sto per dire
potrebbe essere un po' cringe per alcuni
di voi
vi spiego allora sarei dovuta venire qui
con la mia migliore amica però mi ha
gustata Io credo sia uscita con Crash
cioè nulla contro di loro io li scippo
da un sacco di tempo davvero
Però allora lei mi aveva detto di non
dirlo a nessuno io ho fatto la Snitch
con una nostra amica credo che la
situazione l'abbia un po' triggherata e
quindi niente Vabbè sono venuta con i
miei genitori e i boomer Ehi ride ma
perché poi quando ti dice la parola
boomer sono i boomer che ridono perché è
l'unica che capiscono quando la dicono
eh però li rende ancora più boomer vabbè
ve l'avevo detto che sarebbe stato
cringe kringe per chi non lo sapesse
vuol dire imbarazzante
ma non solo perché kringe boomer Crush
switchare scippare ma anche triggerare
Smash droppare e floppare flexare Queste
sono tutte delle parole che ormai sono
entrate a far parte dell'uso colloquiale
del linguaggio della generazione Z sono
parole che potrebbero far sorridere
fanno sorridere ma che a volte
nascondono dei significati inaspettati
io mi occupo di comunicazione e nel mio
lavoro accompagno aziende e brand a
insomma a costruire strategie digitali
per intercettare un determinato target
che è esattamente la generazione Z che
molti di voi sapranno essere la
generazione nata fra il 1997 e il 2012 e
la generazione più numerosa di sempre e
nei prossimi 10 anni 1,3 miliardi della
sua popolazione e dei suoi membri
entreranno a far parte del mondo del
lavoro io non faccio parte della
generazione Z di poco perché ho 29 anni
e sono una mille
nel mio lavoro però passo tanto tempo
online e passo tanto tempo a stretto
contatto con giovanissimi Creator
influencer che hanno milioni di follower
e in questi sei anni da quando ho aperto
la mia agenzia stare così a contatto con
loro mi ha permesso di scoprire e vedere
tanti aspetti che molto spesso vengono
visti in modo un po' superficiale si
dice dell'agenzia che hanno una soglia
d'attenzione di 8 secondi brevissima ma
non si dice che questo aspetto aiuta li
aiuta ad avere un linguaggio più
efficace d'impatto e che li aiuta a
filtrare meglio le informazioni
si dice dell'agenzia fra le tantissime
cose che si dicono che sanno fare cose
contemporaneamente in multicast No hanno
più dispositivi televisione telefono non
si dice però che questo aspetto vero li
rende più esposti a Burnout e stress
si dice della John zie che non amano
incontrarsi dal vivo no sempre online ma
non si dice in realtà che questo non è
vero perché preferiscono incontrarsi dal
vivo e sono assolutamente in grado di
intrattenere delle conversazioni con le
generazioni più adulte e considerato che
molti di loro sono già adulti in
generale quelle generazioni più adulte e
Più anziane di loro si dice dell'agenzia
che stanno sempre online magari su Tik
Tok a fare dei balletti No ma non si
dice che in realtà senz'altro si
divertono ma tanto del tempo che
trascorrono sui social lo usano per
informarsi e per prendere appunti
informazioni su argomenti che gli
interessano o che gli stanno a cuore
ma d'altronde si dicono tante cose ma è
sempre stato così no sta le generazioni
Più anziane categorizzare e giudicare
quelle più giovani Noi millennial siamo
stati demonizzati come mammoni
narcisisti mi ricordo a New York Times
che titolava hanno i soldi per mangiare
l'avocado toast ma non hanno i soldi per
comprarsi una casa
è così nel senso da un punto di vista lo
capisco Cioè In sociologia serve
identificare dei tratti comuni che
accomuna una generazione in base a come
le condizioni economiche sociali e poi
effettivamente hanno un impatto sulle
loro vite Però non capisco questa
tendenza
diciamo così superficiale di
prendere un dato e di pensare che
insomma sia l'unico modo di vedere una
generazione in modo così superficiale
quando Basterebbe veramente poco no Oggi
siamo qui a parlare di parole di
linguaggio basterebbe a volte partire
proprio dalla parola per vedere in che
modo effettivamente possa dirci qualcosa
di che stiamo parlando mi ricordo che
quando avevo 13/14 anni
ho iniziato insomma a troncare le parole
ad accorciarle a scrivere TVB TV
le Storie Tese ci hanno fatto anche una
canzone
In realtà io ho iniziato a farlo perché
gli sms avevano un numero di caratteri
limitati e quindi cioè per non spendere
soldi siamo stati costretti un po' a
troncarle oggi il contesto ci dice
qualcosa di completamente diverso i
social network ci permettono di ricevere
e di vedere contenuti che arrivano da
tutto il mondo e Questo spiega come
tante delle parole alcune che vi ho
Insomma introdotto prima sono proprio
presi in prestito dall'inglese
italianizzate
tipo cringersi io mi cringe tutti cringe
cioè ci sono proprio declinazioni perché
spesso queste parole partono da Insomma
Trend che nascono su Tik Tok piuttosto
che video che vanno in treno su YouTube
su Twitch nelle live un altro dato molto
interessante del contesto e di come
insomma le parole si debbano adattare a
quello che accade è che online
Effettivamente si può parlare di tutto e
nel corso del tempo Le piattaforme hanno
iniziato a perfezionare modellare dei
modelli algoritmici che bannano limitano
le parole che noi usiamo e questo ha
avuto un impatto senza precedenti sulle
parole che scegliamo la generazione Z ha
iniziato a creare un vocabolario
alternativo per poter parlare delle
stesse cose senza farne riferimento
diretto
Quando è esplosa la pandemia globale
meta e altre piattaforme hanno limitato
tante parole che potevano Insomma fare
un espresso riferimento alla pandemia
per evitare Insomma che si diffondessero
fake news informazioni false ma nel giro
di pochissimo tempo si è iniziata a
parlare degli stessi argomenti
utilizzando le parole panini Panda
Express e Backstreet Boys Reunion tour
Se cercate ci sono delle conversazioni
abbastanza accese su come questo
Backstreet Boys Reunion tour si possa
trasmettere tramite WiFi e non si sta
parlando del concerto
Potrei continuare a farvi esempi
dieci anni fa meta ha bannato un elenco
di Oltre 70 # che facevano riferimento e
portavano a Community in cui disturbi
alimentari vengono promossi come stile
di vita
filmspirations proana ci sono dei tempi
di Netlog Insomma non è cosa nuova
bandando queste parole nel giro di poco
sono stati creati hashtag spesso molto
simili spesso cambiando soltanto lettere
e le ricercano dimostrato che questa ha
fatto nascere oltre 200 vocaboli
alternativi aumentando del 30% le
ricerche e quindi
ricerche l'utilizzo di questo tipo di
community
in America la parola suicidio si dice
sui social anal live
rape stupro si dice grave come uva per
parlare del frutto ora si dice il
piccolo frutto Rotondo e verde perché
hanno bannato anche la parola
alternativa
è come se l'elenco di parole
bannandole facesse veramente qualcosa
come se le parole fossero il problema
stesso la parola lesbian in America in
americano inizialmente anzi molto spesso
come accade viene sostituita utilizzando
dei simboli quindi la s è sostituita con
la s di dollaro ora è molto comune
trovare conversazioni purtroppo spesso
omofobe utilizzando il termine il
dollaro bin le Dollar Bean
ma non fa riflettere Come essere
costretti a censurare il linguaggio e
utilizzare un giro di parole per dire
una parola non possa addirittura creare
uno stigma ulteriore attorno a un
determinato concetto
su Tik Tok è esploso da poco un trend il
Trend è mascara mascara Trend ho
riportato il testo non l'immagine del
pov immaginatevi Insomma
sono tantissimi sono più di 200 milioni
e video con questo hashtag di una
ragazza con questo testo di fronte e una
musica di sottofondo Questo è il pov mio
cugino mi ha costretto a mettere il
mascara quando avevo 12 anni non sapevo
nemmeno cosa fosse il make up a quel
tempo ora che ho 23 anni Sono finalmente
libera di decidere se metterlo sto
aspettando di trovare il giusto mascara
per me E fino a che non lo trovo sto
imparando a usare le mie ciglia naturali
andrà meglio lo prometto
avete capito che non si sta parlando del
trucco no
attorno a questo hashtag donne che hanno
subito violenze
raccontano la propria storia e lo fanno
con l'hashtag anche per poter
raggiungere
internazionalmente perché poi Tik Tok ti
permette di andare veramente ovunque e
raccontare così la loro storia
Noi abbiamo principalmente due strade
due scenari diversi il primo Sicuramente
è molto rassicurante No È semplice e
decidere di vedere quello che vogliamo
vedere e di continuare a sentire quello
che ci fanno sentire di continuare a
pensare che il mascara può essere
soltanto un mascara o che su Tik Tok si
fanno solo balletti
oppure c'è un'altra strada che
bisogna rimboccarsi le maniche perché ci
vuole tanto studio Come in ogni
linguaggio bisogna avere la voglia in
questo caso anche di andare oltre a
quello che vediamo oltre a quello che
vogliamo vedere bisogna chiedersi ogni
volta
se c'è altro
e io vi dico una cosa Sì c'è molto altro
grazie
[Applauso]